first question i have for you is kind of
like a fun silly one so let's say you as
in real you you're stuck in a car and
there's a rogue lion stalking you you
could pick two past co-stars to be in
that car with you who do you pick to
give yourself the best chance of
surviving
ooh
wow
two past co-stars for the best chance of
surviving
wow
wow with a lion
in africa i'm gonna go with
it might be cliche but i'm gonna say
liam neeson would be one makes sense
okay um i think the gym would be a good
call and who else
um
probably angelina actually she would be
yeah she would be pretty hardcore i like
that she has like a hardcore edge
so
solid team right there i'm weighing your
team versus idris's team right now who
did he choose he went uh
michael fassbender okay and he also not
me clearly which is a little bit upset
because i thought of saying him and then
i was like i'm not sure
he picked michael fassbender and kate
winslet oh okay okay all right i believe
in both of these teams i'll just give
you both points for this okay i think we
could take them but anyway all right all
right getting into the vfx because
you've done an especially large amount
of films with heavy vfx in it so with
beast it seems like an especially unique
challenge so what is something that you
did for the first time vfx wise on beast
that would make district 9u go like oh
my i never could have imagined that
would be possible this many years later
yeah that's a great question actually
playing with the lions
so there's a scene in the movie uh
i don't know if that's i know where
you're i've already brought it up in
every interview i've done basically
that just blew my mind i basically
wrestle
in a fun playful way because i'm i love
lions in the movie and
the character loves lions martin loves
lines and
it
watching the shots afterwards even
coming from visual effects and being in
visual effects for years
my brain was kind of looping on itself
going like i
but i want that
it's not of line like it wasn't a real
line i'm touching the fur and i'm
playing with it
it was crazy and there was a stunt guy
with the you know
the the gray tights and like lion paws i
mean it looked ridiculous and
on set and the poor guy kept hitting me
and i kept teasing him i'd be like dude
gotta be like a lime they kept making
him do it again and again it was boiling
hot it's like landing on me and it's
like dude like a lion like a land on him
you know that is one of the most
incredible marriages of uh live action
and vfs like you legit hug a vfx lion
and it looks good i was wishing that i
could just say like that i'd done it for
real because it would it seems so cool
it like seems really tough but there's
no way i would go near a real lion and
do stuff like that no chance they'd be
like it's tame i'd be like no probably
the smarter move i respect you for going
this route and not the other um story
wise now so you don't necessarily need
this in the movie but what your
character does fascinates me to no end
so did you ever come up with any
backstory pertaining to you know
specific missions that he's been on in
the past in order to you know help save
wildlife in this region not not
specifically i mean there was just
a lot of growing up in south africa and
you exposed to it quite a bit there's a
lot of obviously
um
people that work and that some of them
like kevin richardson the lion whisperer
you know does amazing work with lions
there's a lot of people that
are conserving animals and are working
in the bush and so just i guess it's
just kind of part of my upbringing
really it's a really nice element of it
that comes through really well and it
makes sure that the rogueline feels like
a threat and it feels like the movie's
thrilling but also doesn't make them
come across like a villain yes and i
appreciate that
um i need to ask you about working with
i guess felipe in particular with these
one ears because these are some really
lengthy shots you have here and they're
complicated too with the heavy vfx and
then some so was this particular
situation a unique relationship between
actor and cinematographer than maybe
you've had in the past it was actually a
very unique situation between
actor and
first camera operator because it was
steadicam most of the time so felipe is
obviously a big component but the actual
operator this south african guy actually
dale rodkin
was
unbelievable with just the amount of
engagement between the camera man
and the actors and the director there
was an amazing i've never had that on a
movie before because we're doing so many
wineries
so dale would constantly be looking at
like well could you do this could you
could you maybe if you move this way can
i move this you know in this direction
so we'd spend sometimes we did some
shots you know do a seven minute take
you rehearse the whole morning
and then you just have like three
chances to get it when the sun is just
perfect so it's pretty it was pretty fun
but it was it was definitely unique
between camera and actor for me it's
very very effective so i have one last
question for you you know where i'm
going with this one what can you tease
about what you're doing as a director
coming up and maybe also just in general
what are some of your priorities as a
director given all your experience
acting what are some you know particular
itches that you will have behind the
lens that you are eager to get to
scratch i'm doing a film that i wrote
and directed and acting called sapient
safari which is basically i play like an
alien naturalist and earth is like a
privately owned reserve by a wealthy
philanthropic alien and it's very
satirical science fiction comedy
and it's probably gonna get me into all
kinds of trouble um and the itch that i
have to scratch is just
somebody make a movie with balls you
know i was prepared to say stuff that
that on people's minds but everyone's
nervous right now everyone's like i feel
like creatives are nervous of their own
shadow so i'm gonna make something and
step off a cliff and either just like
die or people will go like oh finally
you know it's one of the other it's not
i'm i'm not a half measures guy so we'll
see i much prefer movies that have only
reactions on the polar opposite end of
the spectrum and nothing in between
because that's what keeps this business
exciting exactly the worst thing is like
you work for two years on a movie and
then people come out and go like how was
it it was okay i wanted you to come out
and go like i hated that or that was
amazing like that blew my mind then at
least it feels like i'm getting some
reaction otherwise it's just like yeah
it's okay what are we what are we doing
now are we having burgers or like what
are we having i feel ya i believe in you
rooting for that one thank you so much